♪ ♪ ♪
- Kiev est le berceau
de trois états slaves :
l'Ukraine, la Biélorussie et
les histoires de l'Ukrainee e e.
À la fin du 18e siècle,
l'Empire russer r r r r r r r r.
DiDiDiDiDire que l'Ukraine est e
et donc russe revient à détruire
notre idenIgor Ponamarchuk.
Son musée contient la plus
grande collection d'icônes
ukrainiennes, mais aussi
soviétique, qu'il apprécie
beaucoup moins.
"Pendant 400 ans, pour les s st
appelé Empire russe, Fédération
russe, URSS, ces gens de l'est
ont toujours voulu détruire
notre langue, tout."
La langàààààà Zaporijia,
on parle russe.
- C'est historique. Parce que la
langue ukrainienne a été menacée
par les tsars et les empereurs
et le sud de l'Ukraine.
- Je me sensinininininininienne.
Je suis Ukrainienne.
c'est historique. Ça vient de
l'Union NoNoNoNoNoNoNous tous,
on est nés en Union soviétique.
Maintenant, ns enfants,
ils parlent ukrainien.
Ils parlent ukrainien parce que
dans les écoles, ils apprennent
Ça commence. Ça commence.
Ça a déjà commencé.
s'ukrainise, se dérussifie. Ici,
on songe à faire disparaitre
les reliques soviétiques
comme cet avion.
Le monde entier est étonné
par la mobilisation de d d d d é
civile. Dans un pays qui
se méfie de son gouvernement
et des politiciens corrompus,
spontanément.héhéhéhéhéhéhéhésis
cosaques zaporogues, qui, depuis
leur forterrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrn
jusqu'à la fin du 18e s
Dans son roman, Taras Boulba,
cosaque était à cheval
et en armes etetetetetetetetet
que toute une armée était prête
au combat en deux semaines. " "e
mettre le pied dans un
fourmilière. Tout le monde
s'est mis à aider l'a
et les réfugiés. C'est beau
de faire partie de ce mouvement.
L'histoire se fait,
la nation se bat, c'est dur,
mais c'est inspirant."
Les jeunes volontaires de
Zaporijia qussssssssss
pensent déjà à l'après-guerre
quand il faudra éliminerpipipipd
des gouvernements et
des institutions solides.
"À la fin de la guerre, nous
allons construire la nouvelle
Jean-Michel Leprinc